this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live
a meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields milburn and i'm ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists
ryan i love you i love you more
not possible but we'll explain why on
today's episode click here to find out
why brian doesn't love josh moore
rebecca i love you
i love you we have rebecca sharon here
today bex
uh just started a new podcast it's
called how to love so today
we're going to talk about love we're
going to talk about relationships
sex and parenting i think those things
will make their way into it as well
now the name of the podcast she was
gracious enough to ask me to be her
co-host
it's audio only podcast and so um we've
been talking about
love now the name of the podcast is how
to
love but of course that's just a trojan
horse
there's some it's irony right yes yeah
yeah because it's not like
the seven step plan to love although i
wish
that would that be awesome if there was
a set dude it would be awesome if there
was like a seven step plan for a lot of
things
yeah and they're they're all it worked
there are for really like sort of
rudimentary things right you've got you
know
getting out of debt or or losing weight
like there are some really
solid how to's out there we're talking
about love though
we're talking about understanding love
we're talking about exploring
love and that's what i want to explore
with you
and the audience today i think we have a
language problem
now bex and i we talked about this on
the first episode of how to love
really there is you know when i say i
love you
now i might leave here later today and
say i love burritos
right now that's
what i really mean is i enjoy the flavor
of burritos right
and in our new book love people use
things
there's this whole section in there
called love is more you know it's sort
of a play on lessons
more and in that section
we sort of try to give a definition of
love and i found there isn't
a there's not a great definition
for love especially we're talking about
how to be
loving or what it entails to understand
love
it's a rather circuitous path to get
there so i'm not going to read the whole
excerpt here but um
the the part in the book that really
makes sense
for this conversation is this uh
we're talking about the definition of
love one love
involves bottomless devotion birth from
deep affection
the other is a preference or fondness
for something enjoyable so
i love bex but i also love
tacos right all right and so
one is about this devotion the other is
about i
enjoy this thing there's nothing wrong
with that right it's just
it's a word that we use but we use it
rather flippantly and i think that most
of us don't actually
understand love uh and then there's the
distinction between
loving someone and being in love
with them the same word to utterly
different
meanings in the book i go on to explain
how
um the dialect the inuit dialect in
canada has up to at least or up to 53
words to describe snow
and i wish we had that for love
isn't that like the english language has
the most words in it yeah i was just
thinking the same thing out of any
language
but wait one word for love but what's
interesting though in other languages
they have many words for love right yeah
especially go back to
the sort of romance languages and the
roots and latin
and greek and you start to understand
that they're they do have different
descriptors
yeah it's you know the american language
relies a lot on context right and
yeah that's uh it's it's good in the
sense that we don't have to
add more words but when it comes to
something like love
it it muddles things a little bit right
and it makes it harder to
understand which is ironic because love
is ultimately or at least a big
component of it
is about understanding understanding the
way things are understanding
the other person and because i think
with our relationship the thing
that works so well is that we
understand each other yeah and we always
seek to
better understand each other right
there's never an uh
a place where we reach like oh we
understand each other we get each other
it's like no
we understand that we're continually
changing and we're gonna continue to
have to like
adjust and learn each other's new
preferences
now ryan and i had a conversation the
other day about commitment
right and i loved you and i had a
similar conversation it was just
not in front of microphones at the time
and it was after i got home and i had
been speaking to ryan on the podcast
about commitment
and how when you have a deep desire for
something it actually does not require
commitment
and i think sometimes we confuse love or
being in a relationship with someone a
marriage
even a friendship as though you have to
be committed
to that person and you said something
that i think would offend most people
but
it really made me just just overjoyed to
hear
you're like i've never committed to you
can you expand on that yeah i mean i
i don't think i would have thought of it
had the conversation not come up
but like no it's never been a commitment
i've never made this like
well josh and i were in it for life
like better for better or worse like to
death to its part it's like
no like we're we choose to be together
because
we work well together in so many
different ways
and um that doesn't involve a commitment
right
yeah i feel the same way about like ryan
and i have a business together we also
have a friendship together and those
things are
intertwined they can't not be right
right um
but ryan i never feel like i'm
committing
to you in a way it almost feels like
you're getting up at 5am to jog in the
morning i'm committed to this new habit
or whatever
yeah i don't feel that way with you i
don't feel as though i must
commit maybe that's a better way to say
it yeah hmm
it's interesting because uh what's
coming up for me right now
is when i think about mariah and i um
which is so nice that i can talk about
her relationship and she's not here to
uh
to deny anything no actually i don't
yeah she's i would
agree with everything i say yeah no no
um
actually i wish he was here to expound
on this a little bit more but
uh with mariah i
love her deeply and i want to understand
her so i search for
understanding where she comes from yes
where i get stuck and when i get caught
up
is when i get when i feel misunderstood
or
so that feeling can lead to anger um
and then when i'm emotional emotional
like that whether i'm
upset or angry or whatever that negative
feeling
sometimes i forget that
i'm trying to understand her because the
emotion
will overtake and interrupt that deep
love that i have for her
right and it's almost like and it's
usually after
i act like a jerk that i'll go back and
be like you know what i really
wasn't seeking to understand you then
and
you know i i want you to know that i do
want to understand all right i do want
to understand you but i guess
it goes back to this word commitment
because it's almost like
because what you're talking about is
this free flow state of just being with
each other
but there are times when that for me
when that state gets interrupted
and i have to remind it's but it's
almost like that word commitment
when it does come up i'm like you're
really upset right now but like you are
committed to understanding essentially
yeah so
yeah it's interesting how um
you know 90 95 of mariah
and i's relationship is free flow but
that word commitment will come up for me
personally
because that state gets interrupted
right yeah yeah
i think that makes a lot of sense i i
think what you're bringing up though as
that gets interrupted again and again
it sounds to me like what you're saying
is
you get better at understanding each
time you know you're sort of
developing that understanding muscle and
i wish i was getting better at it
are you getting worse no no i'm kidding
i'm kidding no i i think to your point
of like
things are always constantly moving and
changing so you have to adjust
yeah and uh yeah i think i'm probably
getting better at it but there's always
some kind of new understanding that uh
pops up i guess
whether you know it's on the horizon or
whatever but uh but yeah
i was i was kind of saying that
tongue-in-cheek
[Laughter]
well i've got a definition here from the
book i skip ahead of pager two
if you consult your nearest dictionary
you'll find that love
has several meanings an intense feeling
of deep affection
a great interest and pleasure in someone
a person or a thing
that one loves but my favorite
definition
is one i never thought much about the
fourth entry in the new oxford american
dictionary defines love
as a tennis term love
a score of zero ooh isn't that amazing
yeah i forgot about that part in the
book
oh in the context of a tennis match that
means one thing
but as a broader metaphor it means
everything real love when removed from
the desires and commodification of the
modern world
does not keep score there's no
balance sheet no barometer no measuring
stick for love yeah but too often it
feels like we are often creating these
these measuring sticks aren't we yeah
all the time
yeah and i think they manifest in a
bunch of different ways well it's funny
because like you know
uh i this is how i used to approach it
and there's a seth godin article that
does
a much better job of explaining what i'm
about to and i have searched for this
article left and right and like i have
i've spent hours
searching for it i cannot find it but he
he talks about
how keeping score in a relationship is a
zero-sum game
and i'm gonna again i'm gonna try and
explain this but i'm not gonna do a very
good job but uh
when mariah comes home and let's say
i'm on the couch and i'm like oh
mariah's home i'm really excited to see
her she's going to come over here and
give me a kiss
but instead she picks up the cat
and she shows affection to the cat and
then i'm like
what the heck man like i'm over here on
the couch so i've got this expectation
that she doesn't even know about and
then you know as she's petting the cat
i'm like but i came home yesterday and i
went right to her
and gave her a kiss so now i'm keeping
score
of who does what for who and the problem
is that
if you are keeping score eventually
especially because these are
expectations that our partners don't
even know about
sometimes sure you start like it's a
zero it
eventually gets to a zero level where
you're going to feel like
you're going to feel like you're doing
more in the relationship than the other
person
and uh yeah that's just that's the
danger of keeping score but i love this
idea love this idea of love
being a score of zero because
it doesn't start off with this meter
it's just it's it starts at zero
yeah which is um yeah so from there you
can only add
yeah in a way i think you know the one
thing that makes our relationship great
and i
would say the same thing about uh ryan
yours and my relationship
is i feel like we show up full and we're
not we're not expecting to be
filled by the other person no no yes
well sometimes vexes
[Music]
hey oh this just went it's just one
parental advisory
uh yeah you know i was actually thinking
about
what love makes me really want to do and
it's it's uh
it's about showing up for the other
person about supporting the other person
and i think like that is for me
is uh it's a it's a truer definition of
love
not because you know we talk about
unconditional love which i think is
overrated unconditional love is
overrated okay um and i've talked about
this before and i'll tell the story
again real quick uh
bex i don't know if you've actually
heard this but like my so my brother
he uh he came over in montana
meet him and my family and uh we were
having a nice little week vacation
together
and he was just like treating me like
garbage treating the whole family like
garbage i don't know what
anger he was holding in but it was like
this projection of anger
and a certain point i was like what is
your problem man what do you mean
we're family you know we can do whatever
we want i'm like i have friends
that treat me better than you treat me
yeah but they're friends and i'm family
i'm like right
so you should treat me better than my
friends right and that's like he had
nothing he's like oh yeah i see what
you're saying
but the problem is that that
unconditional love
gave him permission to treat everyone
like garbage oh you have to love me
right because i'm your family and it's
uh yeah it's
it's it's overrated i feel like in some
ways i would say that he probably
doesn't understand
that that's not a loving way to behave
right because
if if he was being if
if he understood love
in fact i would make the argument that
unconditional love is the only kind of
love that exists
uh conditional love becomes then
transactional love
and and you must fulfill these the the
sort of terms of service
in order for me to love you that's a
long discussion maybe we can get to that
on the maximal because we have a bunch
of questions to get to today yeah well
it goes back to the definition right
right so unconditional love i think is
oftentimes used how my brother was using
it
where you're coming from with
unconditional love is a it sounds like a
completely different definition
yeah yeah and i don't want to get caught
up on the definition right yes yeah i
think unconditional love is often used
to excuse bad behavior yeah 100 percent
podcast within relationships yeah yeah
no that's
that's absolutely true but for me again
like the the
the love that i truly feel and
experience
it doesn't require any taking
yes yeah that's it and that's why it is
the sort of the score of zero
well the podcast is called how to love
how to love that show
is where you can find it uh it's like
instead of.net or whatever
i i was uh uh i saw your post so i went
to patreon and i
typed in how to love to to go support
bex
and it the first thing that popped up
was how to cat
so i signed up for that instead i'm
sorry bex i understand
the book is called love people use
things it's available for pre-order
right now i love people use
things.net we have a question here from
maureen in
london england i recently got out of a
six-year relationship
um my partner was living with me for the
last 18 months of that relationship and
despite being devastated when it ended
less than two months on i really can see
the relationship for what it was and
actually it was a really
um wise to not be in that relationship
anymore and to
not settle for anything less than what i
deserve um i think it's been a really
good learning experience however
what i'm really conscious of looking at
this relationship and previous
relationships
is that i seem to be making the same
errors
when i'm with someone and i'm allowing
the relationship to drag on for longer
than it should
rather than letting go of it a lot
earlier
it'd be good to hear your thoughts on
how you um
make sure that your feelings of love for
someone don't cloud your judgment
about the reality of a relationship and
how
you can kind of just stay down to earth
about it even
after a long-term relationship
so maureen i applaud you for asking a
question like this because
it sounds to me like if i were to
rephrase the question how do you
recognize when it's time to end
a relationship or what are the
the sort of red flags is that what you
heard bex yeah
let's talk about that yeah so i heard
myself and maureen's question
to be honest my former self okay um
and i might be now just superimposing my
experience onto her so
apologies marine if this is totally not
what you were looking for or what you're
talking about that's exactly what josh
and i do
that's all i know that's the only thing
we do on this podcast is superimpose our
experience on other people
right um so you know she she had the
six-year relationship
um only 18 months of it at the very end
was them living together
so what i'm gonna guess is that at the
start
she was like yeah you know this person
is
someone i enjoy i you know have a few
similarities with
like maybe they have great sex or maybe
they you know have a lot of
snow activities they like to do
snowboarding maybe they got kids
yeah maybe they had kids early on um
or they get attached to kids from yeah
the other person's
former relationships yeah so there are
lots of reasons why you might
get attached early to someone but
at least in my experience especially
with my
my first marriage is like there are
definitely
red flags in relationships that are not
going to work
right and they usually happen early on i
don't remember i feel like
i don't remember who said it but like
the idea of when people show you who
they are believe them
right and you often see exactly who
people are
even within the first two months or the
first six months
definitely within the first year yes and
i think at least what i've often done
is discount
the negative like make excuses for the
red flags like oh it was just you know a
one-time thing or that was a rough
situation or they were really upset
or blah blah blah blah explaining it
away
yeah yeah absolutely giving them giving
myself
permission to not see the red flag
because i don't want to see it what i
want is
this relationship to work because more
than anything else i wanted to be
in a relationship yeah you want the warm
and fuzzies yeah
so to get to those warm and fuzzies you
gotta ignore the bad stuff yeah yeah
so i guess the the like fundamental part
of this question is
or the fundamental part of how you
recognize when it's time to end a
relationship
see the red flags yeah and don't try to
explain them away
and don't examine them yeah examine them
see them understand them
and realize that they're probably not
going to go away yeah
yeah and so then the question then
becomes that
are you willing to pay that cost that is
the cost of admission right right
something else i heard in maureen's
question
is it's almost like she saw the red flag
so she knew it was time to go
but she couldn't let go and
i was thinking about you know uh
because you know i'm still in advice
mode josh i'm like how could i
what advice could i give someone who's
like i'm in a bad relationship i know
it's not working out but it's too hard
to let go
because that's the story of every
relationship leading up to mariah
um to the point where i would like
self-set i would self-sabotage because
then
they would have to leave me in what ways
oh uh like i was a serial cheater
like you know just really flakes yeah
exactly dracula
this episode is brought to you by cereal
anyway
um so so it's uh it's interesting
because
there's always like this black or white
choice i feel like i've always had that
is so difficult
you stay and you get a little bit of the
warming fuzzies but you got to put up
with all the red flags and all the
the bs or you have to leave yes and as i
was thinking this i'm like wait a minute
like there's not just two options
like if you find yourself in a
relationship like it's and people do
this like they step away
they separate for a little bit yes but
you know if you're i think for me the
red flag is
if you're in a relationship and you're
experiencing some of this
discontent or you're not feeling great
about the relationship
ask yourself would i be happier without
this person
and if the initial feeling is i think i
might be happier without this person
then maybe it is time to to choose a
third option
and uh yeah i mean i guess i'm just
trying to get permission
for people to let go when they find
themselves in a situation like this
i love i love the letting go part
especially here because
letting go isn't something you do it's
something you stop
doing you stop tolerating the nonsense
you're talking about here right the
you stop accepting yeah you stop you
stop hanging on
you stop accepting the red flags for
what they were or
in order to let go of them you
can change your beliefs around those
well because sometimes i think quite
often what needs to happen
in these scenarios is i need to do a
better job
understanding my beliefs around
something
it it may not be the truth it may just
be some way that i've been indoctrinated
to
to believe that you are supposed to
you know whatever fill in the blank not
drink or you are supposed to drink in
order for us to have a
uh relationships and go out together
whatever it is right
but these are just beliefs and so
sometimes
letting go of the beliefs can save the
relationship i was clinging to the
the the to disempowering beliefs
yeah i think at the end of the day i'm
going to pick up on your
beloved phrase i am honored sorry at the
end of the day it's like it just like
comes this way at the end of the day
yeah
anyway actually i won't derail this i
won't derail this specs please
um i think that for me anyways what's
been
helpful with figuring out when it's time
to end a relationship is listening to
your intuition right and listening to
those those
internal cues that are telling you like
this
this isn't the right place to be
um yeah and you get there by a
combination of
you know the red flags and thinking
about whether or not you'd be happier by
yourself or not
or yeah um well she did say that she
sometimes worries that love clouds
judgment and i would say there are three
components in your relationship we talk
about this and love people use
things and initially got this from
our friend chris ryan uh he wrote the
book saxodon wrote civilized to death
and his concept of
relationships involve sort of a
three-legged table
right and it requires all three legs to
hold up the table
and too often we fulfill
one or two of these legs and the other
one's either short or missing
and so the table falls over so the first
one
is chemistry and that's the thing that
makes the relationship really easy up
front right because you have that the
chemistry sexual chemistry or just
enjoy being around each other the news
the same music yeah
yeah right there's there's a particular
energy there at the onset of a
relationship
and that can last for a long time that
flame burns
hot um but it it does
stay lit for a while i say a long time
it could be a month two months
six months a year but eventually
if the relationship is predicated solely
on
chemistry we know what that what their
whole
sitcoms that are that are dedicated to
exposing this lie of life
well this makes me think you said love
clouds the judgment
uh-huh but yeah that's what that's what
she's saying but it's almost like
it's the pleasure that clouds the
judgment exactly that we confuse for
love
bingo or we could even say the chemistry
here yeah so the second component
is compatibility the third component is
love
now of all of those love is the one we
understand the least
again i think love it really
involves a deep understanding acceptance
and appreciation not of the way you hope
things to be
but of the way things are warts and all
not trying to change the other person
that's not loving that's coercion
remember when mike tyson was yelling at
the reporter i'm gonna
[ __ ] you till you love me
but that's how we treat relationships uh
maybe literally but i mean figuratively
it's like
i'm going to persuade you force you drag
you
into love with me but but you can't
induce
love love doesn't work that way now
compatibility on the other hand
i think that might be the most difficult
of
the three components in fact it's the
reason that i think
most marriages or relationships
boyfriend girlfriend
whatever partnerships they
they carry on for such she talks about
six years
well compatib being incompatible is
is easy to deal with
but you don't want to deal with it
imagine having to deal
with your relationship right like it's
like what do you do pain
management for your relationship no of
course you don't want to deal with your
relationship
you want your relationship to be
thriving can i add something here
of course you're the guest i think that
one of the things that we struggle with
with
compatibility in romantic relationships
in particular
is the idea that we're really
incompatible with almost everyone we're
around
all the time right and so we're used to
being
incompatible we're used to trying to
navigate like
the weird places where things don't
sync up right where you don't see eye to
eye we're used to trying to
quote unquote make it work right
and so we then transfer that to romantic
relationships
and we put up with being incompatible
with people that we
you know we we get we have chemistry
with them
and eventually maybe the chemistry
evolves into some sort of
love and we're kinda
compatible right right right but it's
not it's not working
right the table is wobbly yeah yep i'm
just really grateful for
uh okcupid's algorithm that uh that's
the first thing that like
drew me to mariah was because when she
reached out to me she had no pro there
was no profile yeah
she just like filled out the
questionnaire but we were like a 92 or
93
match and i was like oh like i know that
i have no idea what this person looks
like
but uh she did end up like emailing me a
picture or something
um it was uh it was just a picture of an
eggplant
no but uh but from her garden but it's
but i i actually am being serious like
there is
like algorithms out there to help you um
i'm not saying everyone can rely on
these but that is it was the
compatibility part that really
made me excited about going on that
first date with mariah i'm like weird 93
this is the highest match yeah that i've
had on this website and
every date i went up to or uh went on
leading up to that you know it was like
85 86
and it was always like good good
compatibility and yeah it's
there is an algorithm that totally like
helped mariah and i get together based
on compatibility
and if you're looking for another
algorithm maybe a deeper algorithm
something deeper than an algorithm yes
we have a values worksheet on our
website the minimalists.com
v and there is an essay there about
understanding
your values it's a free worksheet you
can download it
actually stem from bex and i we we
started writing out our values on like
notepads and apple notes and stuff and
eventually we we discovered uh talking
with ryan as well there are
these four different types of values
well three and then there's imaginary
values and we go into detail on that but
understanding what your values are can
help with that compatibility component
as well
because if you val value everything
different
from your partner is there going to be
much compatibility there
no of course not so the minimalists.com
v you can download the free
values worksheet over there and read the
essay about understanding
your values we're running out of time so
i'm going to go
past billy's question because i want to
make time well
for what time it is right now ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it
is time for our lightning round where we
answer your text messages you can text
your questions and comments to
937-202-4654
shout out to everyone who's been sending
us pictures of what they're decluttering
recently so many people taking the less
is now challenge after watching the film
and so they're posting it with the
hashtag less is now on social media
tagging us we're just at the minimalists
but also uh bex and i have been doing
the the challenge as well this month um
day 31 will surprise you i'll tell you
that um
and day 32 will surprise you with yeah
well uh uh you can follow beck's minimal
wellness on instagram to see
how our family is decluttering or you
can just send us a text message with
what you are letting go of this month by
the way those texts go to both
my phone and ryan's phone we respond to
quite a few of them and
we respond to some on the podcast now
during the lightning round this is where
ryan and i and our guests we do our best
to answer every question with a short
shareable
less than 140 character response we put
the text to these minimal maxims in the
show notes so you can
copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like and now you
can find all of our minimal maxims in
one place
minimal maxims.com we have a special
question today
ryan from our mvp official tk coleman
that's right he's official he is
official
eight-time podcast guest is he yeah he
he holds the record that's awesome
i wish he was here in person to ask this
question
he asks do you ever passionately
disagree about
important decisions that affect the
entire
family for example where should we live
where should we send our
child to school etc if so how do you
handle
compromise in conflict resolution
bex how do you handle compromise and
conflict resolution god i love this
question
um tk you're gene you're a genius
um you know
you and i
i have to say we don't often
passionately disagree that's true um
and we don't start if you'd like yeah i
know right shut up
yeah i can't imagine so
yeah i think at least for us part of
this question is kind of hard
because i think part of the there are
several reasons why we don't
passionately disagree first of all we're
hyper compatible
um and the stuff that we're not quote
unquote compatible about yes
uh you know for example um
affinity for nature yeah
uh tolerance of dirt yes yeah yes
uh like
josh hates pretending that he's homeless
we both appreciate where the others
coming from
right and like i'm not gonna try to
bully you into
doing something my way or vice versa
definitely not um
and so i think there's a certain go
going back to the understanding thing
understanding your your partner's
preferences
right and not trying to force your
preferences on your partner
that's my actual my pithy answer here is
because he asked
where where should we live where should
we send our child to school
my pithy answer is is rather pithy it's
just there is no should there never
was these shoulds even the ones he
describes are really good examples of of
of common problems that come up in a
relationship
and it's because they're they're
problems only because we believe they're
shoulds
we put this like pressure on ourselves
to do something when
there was the only pressure that exists
is what we have put on it
yes yeah 100 of the time and so these
are these shoulds are all manufactured
and they're it's really saying well i
have a preference to send our kid to
this school you have a preference
for that school and in bex's in my
relationship i know that we could
talk about that and then we
as we communicate we do a better job of
understanding like
okay what what are your beliefs around
this what are my beliefs around it and
how do i untangle those beliefs to get
to
some sort of essence yeah yeah bex i
like what you have written here
did you did you say this did you say you
put the answer i didn't say my picture
okay so you say your pithy answer first
because mine is very similar to yours
and i don't want to steal your thunder
oh you're so sweet i do it again
um okay so my pithy answer is respect
and appreciation help us find compromise
and resolve conflict yes so i totally
agree with that so mine is disagreements
are easier to solve when we
approach them with love and
understanding so
this makes me think about this word
passionately inserted here before the
word disagree
and i think what happens is we get
passionate
about an emotion that we have or a
belief
or whatever it is so then we project
that's that's what the passion means to
me because you know this is
this passionate here before disagree is
not this sounds like a pejorative to me
it doesn't sound
like something positive so i think if
you approach
any disagreement or any decision made
your decision with
uh with love with understanding with
respect with appreciation
i think uh you can actually just have a
disagreement and not a passionate
disagreement
but you know it's it's interesting i had
this little aside here with i'm sorry
were you gonna say something no
okay you're disagreeing with me awesome
all right sweet
so uh my my little aside here is that
with disagreements
we often try when we're passionately
disagreeing we often
try to convince someone of something
and uh i love that josh and i are trying
to get away from
from the convincing business yes so
uh if you're trying to convince someone
there's probably something wrong
and when we have these passionate
disagreements even worse
we might actually to a certain degree be
trying to take something away from
someone
whether it's an idea or a preference or
a point of view so
um really you know what i what i have
written here is like
an argument is best solved when both
sides
are trying to find a way to give rather
than take
and if both people can approach it in
that way
you can get through these disagreements
so instead of trying to
convince someone or to take someone's
idea away
really approach and this is what i do
with mariah because it actually makes me
feel
because of the the love i have for her
it makes me feel so good to like give
her something so when
we have a disagreement and uh that
emotion isn't clouding
my my my my judgment at that time
you know i can get into a space a lot of
the times where i'm like oh she's asking
for something
that i want to give her and then once
she sees me giving her something she
will then in turn
give me something back so uh yeah um
tk great question uh i know that him and
his wife are not passionately
disagreeing about a lot of things though
yeah because they seem like a very
awesome couple
they are they're wonderful uh i will say
that you know the word compromise
stood out to me bex and maybe we could
talk about that because i want to echo
orion said here with respect to arguing
i think that arguing is solved only when
we understand why we're arguing
yeah sometimes we're arguing because we
feel insignificant
i i feel like i'm not being heard
i feel like i'm competing against you
even in our own relationship or maybe
even especially in our own relationships
we compete against the person i'm
smarter than you faster than you
whatever it is like
more i'm kinder than you right i'm more
compassionate than you
and it become we become martyrs for our
own relationship
now bex you talked about compromise here
in your answer
and you know i'm of two minds of of uh
compromise i i actually feel very
similar to it as i do
commitment in a way i feel that it
becomes an obligation in fact we
we feel as though it is noble or
virtuous
to compromise and i believe there are
times where we have to
give up something to get something and
if that's what we mean by compromise
wonderful if we mean that we must do
things repeatedly that we dislike
in order to make a relationship work
then i hate that and i don't want to
compromise at all
amen yeah yep anything to add to that
no agreed that was perfect all right joe
well we got some listener tips today we
also have a
added value segment about love but it
looks like we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week ryan like
how do you find the balance between
being a couple and being individuals
bex and i we talk about this one a lot
so i think we'll uh we'll be able to go
in depth on that that's easy one person
lives in montana half of the time
right yeah what about the other half
easy
[Laughter]
what are your fears and insecurities as
you settle into your relationship
can you discuss your thoughts on
non-monogamy
do you really did you really get married
or do you just say you're married
without
the big cost and paper um okay
how do you tell your partner how do you
help your partner who isn't a minimalist
part with material items
what is your favorite tinder profile
what's in your fun
box actual question plus a million more
questions for bex and
the minimalist if you want to hear all
that join us on the minimalist
private podcast this week that's right
we release a second private podcast
episode every week on patreon
that's one free minimal episode every
tuesday that's the one you're listening
to
right now and one completely separate
long form maximal episode every thursday
so
visit theminimalists.com support to
subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
private podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app you also
get access to hundreds of hours of
archives
i mean it just goes way way way back
you've got a lot of catching up to do
dude if we if i uh was a listener and
not like the host of this
co-host of the show i would sign up just
for
the biggest failures honestly yeah the
biggest failure segment so we have
guests do
beck's did hers already we they they do
like a little five minute video about
something they failed failed at and the
lessons they've learned from that so
we've got all the archives there
live events etc keeps our show 100
advertisement free
and it's cheaper than a cup of coffee
visit the minimalists.com
support to subscribe ryan what else you
got for us this week here are some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners check them out hello this is
maurice bradley watson calling out of
tampa florida
and i just wanted to bring up a line of
thought in regards to the selling part
of decluttering
when it comes to minimalism the first
half is a list of price points to
consider when selling some of your
unused stuff
and the second half is the philosophy
behind why letting go is okay
even when you may not be 100 happy with
it
so here are five price points to
remember and consider when reselling an
item one the price you paid for it sans
tax
to the used price sales tax which is
always half the original price this is
what
most people want out of their items but
it's not what they'll always get
three the market price for similar items
for the price the consumer wants to pay
for the item
and five the price you want or will
settle for
when it comes to the item one thing to
remember
is that you don't actually own anything
that may be a difficult concept to grasp
but let me explain
everything you buy is a remaining
lifetime rental
meaning that when you're no longer here
your lease is up
and your stuff is not coming with you
where it goes from
there is up for you to determine while
you're still here
but let's say you get a brand new couch
for five hundred dollars and use it for
five years
you may not get 250 out of it you may
only get fifty to a hundred dollars but
even at that
you have the experience of owning that
couch for better or worse
in if you discount the amount you resold
the couch for
you can count that as how much you
initially paid for it and if you do feel
bad about spending as much as you did
initially
taking off that one hundred dollars can
help you feel so much better
so way you say if this is a remaining
lifetime rental what happens when i
break the lease
and i resell it now that's actually a
really fun part
because most times when you break a
lease you have to pay a fee but in this
scenario you're actually getting paid
but anyway i found that looking at
things this way has really helped me
declutter and let go
hi my name is jess and i have gone from
being a shopaholic to a minimalist and
it has completely changed my life i just
wanted to kind of share with you
a more effective form
of using the one and one out rule that
has worked for me
so well that i've never even had to make
a swap
so with the one and one outro one really
good example is
the first step to that being effective
is to
declutter honestly you know when you get
rid of your stuff
be honest with yourself like for example
for me like my jewelry collection
um i had so much jewelry but i only wore
like five things so
it took like three to four times and i
finally decluttered everything and i
just have
one necklace i have one ring and then a
couple pair of earrings and that's it
you know
so if i see this necklace in the store
and i'm just like
oh i really want that necklace instead
of thinking well i'll just buy it and
get rid of a pair of socks
it doesn't work that way if you if you
buy a necklace
you have to get rid of a necklace you
have to get rid of a like item
and the reason why that works so well
for me is because i have
reduced my clutter so much that i only
own one necklace and i love it so much
it's so special to me
there's no way i would buy another
necklace
and replace it so it's just it's really
worked for me all right y'all since
we're talking about love
today i thought for our added value
segment we would recommend a song
in fact i think we'll play it at the end
of the audio version sorry if you're
watching this on
youtube jordan we'll just play our
regular theme song by peter doran
but there's a song we have here today
called easy to love
by michael flynn ryan and i saw michael
flynn he is the lead singer of a
band called slow runner where did we see
him he opened for william fitzsimmons
at the canal street tavern in downtown
dayton ohio yeah
and it was a really late show it was
really late and like
uh fitz simmons came out he's like are
you guys ready to be sad
yeah which you juxtapose him with
michael flynn's music which is like
really upbeat and kind of like
poppy but the lyrics are so deep he had
one of my favorite albums of 2020.
the album is called survive with me
which great title for a pandemic album
right survive with me yeah and i feel
like in many ways bexa
you know in 2020 there was a lot of
surviving together
right if we're not thriving together
we're surviving together
and and that togetherness has um
certainly made my life a lot better and
i'm grateful for that
so let's listen at the end of this
episode to easy to love
by michael flynn because i do think when
love
is done well it is easy it is
simple it requires very little effort to
love unfortunately we cloud it up
with uh we junk it up with uh
complexities
right real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalist well sort of
adjacent to the minimalist bex has her
new podcast how to love
how to love dot show is where you can
find it and uh we're talking
twice a month on the podcast i think
it's the first and the 15th
we've already done a few episodes out
there the third episode comes
out next week and so bex um
you decided it's not everywhere the
podcast is not
wherever podcasts are found you always
hear people say there listen wherever
you find podcasts
you can't do that with this one this is
a private podcast it is
yeah and so um howtolove.show
is the only place that you can find it
yeah it's on patreon that's right
all right y'all you can follow the
minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalist follow bex
on instagram
at minimal wellness come to one of our
live podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com tor to find a city
near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo
to podcast at theminimalists.com you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalist
and if you want our show notes in your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple
sunday emails whenever we send those and
if you leave here today with just one
message we hope it's this
[Music]
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it
bye